welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is tonya sanchez an assistant professor
of political science at yale university
her teaching and research focus on
international cooperation and
international law in particular she
studies how international law and
organisations shape international
security and human rights policy she is
currently working on a book on the
domestic political factors that affect
treaty compliance today we talk with
Professor Sanchez about her supply-side
theory of treaty implementation and
compliance welcome professor Sanchez
thank you for having me let us talk
about your theory give us an overview so
the piece that I'm working on right now
has to look at domestic factors that
affect whether countries comply with
human rights agreements particularly
because of a political scientist the
politics that surround treaty
ratification and treaty implementation
and by that I mean how countries
actually take a treaty and make it part
of their domestic law outcome
institutions and I there's a lot of
research and political science in this
area but a little bit has looked at the
role that NGOs or other groups and civil
society have pushed States to adopt
treaties and implement them but not a
lot of work has looked at what i call
the supply side which is the government
mainly how legislators and executives go
about actually passing the loss and
putting them into the books so that
states can be in compliance with
international agreements okay what led
you to this work and how are you doing
the research so it started as part of my
doctoral work I was looking at trying to
explain why some countries seem to
undertake some international treaties
and do fairly well in complying but
others don't so it's sort of a puzzle
that I sought out to explore and one
that a lot of other scholars have
looked into and I started to look more
at the politics surrounding that and the
way I went about the research was by
first starting to look at what states
have actually done after they've
ratified agreements which you think that
would be a pretty obvious place to start
but there was not a lot of data so I
started by actually collecting a lot of
data going through each country's penal
codes and also the records of how
legislators debated different bills to
implement treaties into their domestic
legal system so I started by collecting
a lot of data and subsequently doing
some statistical analysis using that
data okay let's talk specifics what are
some of the countries that you could
cite for instance that may have enacted
a treaty a little bit differently than
perhaps a different another country are
there any correlations there are
differences that you could speak to oh
there's there's once you start looking
there wide differences and this is
what's interesting about the project so
when I started looking at their penal
codes there they all start all the
country start with the same treaty and
in one of the treaties i was looking was
a convention against torture okay and
they all started they all ratify the
treaty and so you would think that they
all of their loss would pretty much
mirror what the treaty said criminalized
torture put some sanctions and I started
by looking at Latin America because the
region is very uniform and lots of
variables that allow me to control for
other circumstances they if you look at
the definitions they define torture very
differently from country to country for
instance countries like Paraguay will
make a requisite that you prove intent
when you're trying to convict somebody
of the crime of torture which is not
part of the treaty they just sort of
threw that in there the sanctions vary
widely so you have a country like
Argentina that will punish torture from
eight to twenty years Wow but Paraguay
will be like two months to six months
so two months six months 8 to 20 years
big discrepancies so I thought why why
are some countries being very strong
implementers really following the treaty
putting strong sanctions why do we have
other countries that have you know
definitions that don't conform to the
treaty and sanctions that are you know
very weak and might not get us to and
how does your theory explain these
differences these variances politics
okay I'm the theory sort of has a lot to
do with who is in power not just at the
time that the treaty was ratified but
who is in power when they actually have
to put the loss in the books the
preferences of the party in power but
not just what their preferences are but
also who their political opposition is
and whether they can actually get those
laws through the legislative process as
you know getting a bill you know past is
very complicated so often miracle when
it happened yes it is so now I don't
only looked at how the politics affected
you know amendments of bills but the
time that it took some countries take
after they ratified 32 years by the to
get the law some countries like Uruguay
20 years why did it take 20 years well
they couldn't agree and then the bill
was killed in committee and then it just
didn't get picked up again until they
had to change the power another party
came in they retook the bill finally
passed it through I had more support
they had a majority in the legislature
so they didn't have to deal with a lot
of them the hassles that it takes for a
bill to get through so I look at that
process and explain how you know when
they disagree about what should what
they want domestically to happen it
stalls the process and so we have a lot
of states that get stuck in that process
it's a long and complicated process so
how does your supply side theory differ
from current thinking it doesn't
necessarily differ it sort of
supplements a side that has hadn't been
studied a lot of other theories which I
call the demand side explain
how different people within the polity
demand that the state undertake these
agreements and implement them and so
that research has looked a lot of how
NGOs civil society activists lawyers etc
push the government to actually get
those laws in the books so they're
looking sort of a one piece of the
puzzle and I'm looking at another piece
of the puzzle but they going to
complement each other because a lot of
the states don't really get these bills
going until there is that you know
demand from the people but then I go in
and say but it's that's not enough the
demand is not enough you still have to
have enough support within the
legislature to get those bills going and
actually get it in the books and then
subsequent to the law being passed to
actually fulfill the law train your
police I locate fonts you know develop
the policies that really get compliance
with the treaties and that takes a lot
of a lot of work do you ever think that
there will be a time when treaties can
be enacted on an equal level where one
country does it the same as another
country it seems like politics will
always have some role to play in that
process I don't think that they'll ever
be identical and but I think that's a
good thing because not all countries are
identical so you need to allow for some
countries to sort of you know tailor it
for their own individual situation their
own legal systems vary widely so what
makes you know a law that makes a lot of
sense in one country and another country
wouldn't work particularly well but you
what you don't want is huge
discrepancies so you need to narrow that
gap of what's what's acceptable
variation and I think that part of how
you achieve that is by writing better
treaties the treaties leave up a lot of
room for interpretation you know they'll
say something like don't torture torture
bad don't do it but then they leave a
lot of the rest up to the states to fill
in the blanks and so if we were able to
write better treaties and maybe also at
the international level give
implementation assistance to
countries so they have a better idea of
what the international community expects
when they undertake these treaties that
we would see the less variation okay and
in terms of any conclusions that you
have in terms of policy and and how best
you know to move forward with enacting
treaties what would you suggest I think
from the international community is give
a lot more assistance to States both
legal technical assistance so to
legislators to give them sample
legislation of what we expect you to
look at a lot of the times states have
to draft their own from scratch and this
is why we see a lot of variation but in
other treaties we have seen that
international bodies like the UN will
present to them a sample legislation
that often states just identically take
it and try to pass that through also
make it requirement that states actually
pass a law within a time period and not
allow states to you know go on 20 years
or so without actually doing something
so following up with the states and
giving them assistance helping them what
is it that's telling the process
sometimes there's not much you can be
done because of its politics you just
have to wait till then till you know
there's a configuration that comes in or
try to convince them and that that's
where the civil society part is
important to try to persuade the
legislators and the people that this is
a desirable bill and that it should be
passed so there's a lot of things that
can be done depending on whether you
want to operate domestically or whether
you want to operate at it from an
international level so we think that o
scholars think that there's a lot of
capacity building that could help
countries giving them the right tools to
achieve the treaty goals right okay very
good thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work great thank you for having me be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International
area studies at Yale
you